Today’s protagonist was one of the key players
on the giant chessboard that was Asia at the
height of the Cold War.
Born into a political family, she rose through
India’s political system until she became
the first and only female Prime Minister of
her country.
Her name was Indira Gandhi.
In one of her speeches, she advised her followers
to maintain a ‘bias toward action,’ or
to encourage societal change, even if required
painstakingly small steps.
Her life was definitely true to that principle:
as the second longest-running Indian Prime
Minister, Mrs. Gandhi won a war, oversaw the
birth of a new State, broke the traditional
non-aligned stance of India, and even made
of her country a nuclear super-power.
But it was her internal policies that made
her mandate controversial, and eventually
turned her into a target of hatred.
Welcome to today’s Biographics, in which
we will look at the private and public life
of Indira Gandhi, and how it all led to a
fateful appointment with the very people who
were meant to protect her.
Setting a good example
Indira Gandhi was born Indira Nehru on the
November 19th, 1917, in Allahabad, in the
state of Uttar Pradesh, India.
She was the first-born child of Kamala and
Jawaharlal Nehru, who were no ordinary family.
Kamala came from a conservative family of
Kashmiri Brahmins -- the category of priests
and teachers, according to the traditional
Indian caste system.
This initially shy girl became an independence
activist after meeting her future husband,
Jawaharlal Nehru.
Nehru was a well-educated lawyer and one of
the most active members of the Indian Independence
Movement, fighting for self-rule against the
British Empire.
As such, he was a close associate to the Mahatma
Gandhi, and would later serve as the first
Prime Minister of an independent India.
While Nehru and Gandhi’s fight for independence
through non-cooperation is widely known, Kamala’s
role may have been overlooked.
Beginning in 1921, Kamala was actively involved
in the Non-Cooperation movement, organising
boycotts and picketing lines against shops
selling British goods.
When her husband was jailed by the colonial
authorities, Kamala shed her natural shyness
to deliver speeches to thousands of followers
on his behalf.
With such fierce examples set by both her
parents, it is no wonder that little Indira
wanted to join the active struggle as early
as possible.
At age five, she carried out her first act
of rebellion: she sacrificed her beloved doll
– made in England – by throwing it onto
a bonfire of imported British goods.
Two years later, in 1924, the Nehru family
welcomed a second child, a boy, also born
in November.
Unfortunately, the newborn died after only
two days, and Indira grew up as an only child.
In 1929, she escalated her commitment to the
cause of self-determination.
As a girl of only 12, Indira became a leader
within an organisation numbering 60,000 young
revolutionaries, called Vanar Sena, or ‘Monkey
Brigade’.
This name was inspired by the traditional
epic Ramayana, in which an army of monkeys
helps Prince Rama to defeat the despotic and
monstrous Ravana.
The Vanar Sena’s mission was less bellicose,
but still dangerous, as it involved managing
the communications and logistics that powered
mass demonstrations and protests.
In March 1930, Indira and Kamala were participating
in one of such protests outside Ewing Christian
College in Allahabad.
Indira's mother suddenly collapsed, due to
a heat stroke.
An eighteen-year old student of the College
rushed to her aid.
His name was Feroz Gandhi -- no relation to
the Mahatma.
This chance encounter would prove one the
most important for Indira’s life so far.
Feroz became a good friend of both Indira
and her mother, even helping to look after
Kamala when she later contracted tuberculosis.
By 1936, Kamala moved to Switzerland to treat
her tuberculosis, but this was in vain: she
passed away on February 28, 1936, while her
husband was in prison.
Shortly after her mother’s death, Indira
traveled to Britain to enroll at Somerville
College in Oxford to complete her studies.
She never attained a degree, though, as her
concentration may have been swayed by a big
distraction, one that happened to be studying
at the nearby London School of Economics:
Feroz Gandhi.
Mrs and Mr Gandhi
Indira and Feroz rekindled their friendship,
which turned into a courtship, and then into
an engagement.
Like Indira, Feroz was also well-educated
involved in the independence movement, and
he loved Indira.
Despite all this, his potential father-in-law
Nehru, objected to the union.
Nehru simply had a personal dislike of the
young Gandhi, and as father of the bride,
he was entitled to a powerful opinion.
As the Nehrus were a family under the spotlight,
many ordinary citizens also chipped in to
criticise the engagement, on the basis that
he was a Parsi, not a Hindu like Indira, or
that non-arranged marriages were not the norm.
In fact, there was such a public outcry against
the match that the other Gandhi, the Mahatma,
had to offer a public statement of support,
which included the request:
"I invite the writers of abusive letters to
shed your wrath and bless the forthcoming
marriage."
Despite the objections and the abuse, Indira
taught everybody a lesson in determination
by marrying Feroz on March 26, 1942.
Two years later, Indira gave birth to her
first son Rajiv, followed in 1946 by Sanjay.
Unfortunately, this marriage was not a happy
one.
Feroz began having extramarital affairs almost
immediately.
Things only got worse after August 15, 1947.
This is the date in which Nehru became the
first Prime Minister of an independent India,
to which he added the title of Foreign Minister
in the October of the same year.
In this capacity, Nehru handled the first
of many crises over Kashmir, a border region
disputed with Pakistan.
As work kept on piling up on Nehru’s desk,
he enlisted his daughter Indira to help as
his personal assistant.
This was an unofficial role, although it became
apparent to him and to the leadership of his
party – the Indian National Congress, or
INC – that Indira’s contribution was key
to carrying out his functions.
Indira was spending more and more time with
his father’s cabinet, eventually moving
away from her hometown of Allahabad to the
capital, Delhi.
Her two sons followed her, while Feroz decided
to stay back to concentrate on his work editing
‘The National Herald’ … but this arrangement
also gave him free rein to pursue more clandestine
liaisons.
During this de facto separation, Indira appeared
to be completely absorbed by her administerial
and political duties.
This is probably the truth; however, we should
mention that a book published in 1978 presents
a different image.
This is the autobiography of M.O.Mathai, Private
Secretary to Prime Minister Nehru from 1946
to 1959.
The 28th chapter, titled ‘She,’ was removed
from the final edition, but it has recently
re-emerged thanks to Indian online media.
According to the chapter, Indira tried to
seduce Mathai in November 1947, and quite
aggressively so.
He yielded the day after, but due to being
completely inexperienced, Indira had to first
‘educate’ him by giving him two books
about sex and the female anatomy.
The chapter alleges that the clandestine relationship
continued for more than 10 years, until the
winter of 1958.
While visiting Indira on urgent official business,
Mathai caught her with another man, a yoga
instructor.
This chapter may have not even been written
by Mathai, and even if it were, Indira’s
close associates strongly refuted these rumours.
According to a former leader of the Indian
National Congress, Natwar Singh, it would
have been materially impossible for Indira
to carry out some dangerous liaisons.
According to Singh,
“It was just not possible for her to have
an affair, there were security men under the
bed!
… Of course, you’re not made of wood but
this is the price you pay – you don’t
have a private life.”
First Steps on the Political Scene
Despite their marital issues, the Gandhis
presented a united front in the arena of Indian
politics.
During the Parliamentary Elections in 1951-52,
Indira became the campaign manager for Feroz.
Indira clearly had a knack for campaigning
and succeeded in securing a victory for her
husband.
After starting to serve as an MP, Feroz had
to move to Delhi, but he did not join his
family, preferring to live in a separate house.
From then on, both Gandhis made their bid
to grow in status within the ruling party,
the Indian National Congress, although admittedly
in two very different fashions.
Feroz did so by exposing the corruption within
his father-in-law’s government.
He exposed a major scandal involving bribes
paid by prominent insurance companies to the
Finance Minister T.T. Krishnamachari.
Because of this, Feroz began to emerge as
the new rising star within India’s political
circles.
On the other hand, Indira was following another
route, rising from the inside of the INC party’s
structure.
In 1955, Indira first became a member, and
then a president, of the working committee
of the Indian National Congress -- the inner
circle that decided the party’s policies.
In 1958, Feroz suffered a heart attack during
a state visit to Bhutan.
Indira rushed him back to Delhi and took care
of him for the following year.
She still managed to advance her career within
the party, and in 1959, Indira became President
of the Indian National Congress.
Marred by poor health, Feroz could not match
her rise, On the September 8, 1960, he suffered
another cardiac arrest.
This time, it was fatal.
The marriage of Indira and Feroz had not been
the happiest.
In addition to affairs and long periods of
separation, their life was marred by frequent,
vicious arguments.
According to Indira’s biographer Sagarika
Ghose, this was because both were extreme
individualist, with an urge to dominate the
other.
And yet Indira remembered those confrontations
with fondness:
“I like to think that those quarrels enlivened
our life, because without them, we would have
had a normal life but banal and boring.
We didn’t deserve a normal banal and boring
life.”
Taking Centre Stage
Shortly after the death of Indira’s husband,
her father’s health began declining.
It did not help that in July 1962, India and
China entered a War over some border disputes,
which ended with a Chinese victory in November.
Nehru’s conditions worsened, leading to
his death on May 27, 1964.
Nehru was succeeded as Prime Minister by Lal
Bahadur Shastri, who appointed Indira as Minister
of Information and Broadcasting.
As a Minister, Indira proved very adept at
building her image with well-planned publicity
stunts, such as the one taking place during
the Indo-Pakistani War of 1965.
This confrontation over the control of the
Kashmir border region took place from the
5th of August to the 22nd of September in
1965, when a UN resolution finally imposed
a ceasefire.
That summer, Indira planned a holiday retreat
at Srinagar, in Kashmir.
Despite repeated warnings by the security
forces that Pakistani troops had advanced
very close to her hotel, Indira Gandhi refused
to move.
The incident fetched her huge national and
international media attention.
It would take only a few months for Indira
to take a role at the centre of the stage.
On the 11th of January 1966, Prime Minister
Shastri died.
Immediately, his fellow party members began
squabbling and plotting to appoint a successor.
The leadership of the Indian National Congress
was by then split into two currents, one more
conservative, the other with socialist leanings.
These divisions made them unable to settle
on a candidate, and so they started considering
an appointment for Indira Gandhi.
They had been led to believe that she was
a goongi Gudiya, or ‘dumb doll’, easily
manipulated.
The perfect compromise candidate, then!
After much deliberation, Indira was chosen
as the Prime Ministerial candidate by the
Congress high command.
Indira campaigned hard and emerged victorious
on January 24, 1966.
At the age of 49, Indira Gandhi had become
the Prime Minister of one of the largest and
most populous countries on Earth.
She was not the first ever woman to be elected
head of state or head of government; in fact
she was only the third.
The honour to be the first belongs to Khertek
Anchimaa, Chairwoman of the Tuvan’s People
Republic, from 1940 to 1944.
The country was annexed by the USSR and does
not exist anymore.
The first-elected Prime Minister of a still
existing country was Sirimavo Bandaranaike:
in 1960, she became the head of Government
in Sri Lanka, back then called Ceylon.
So, Mrs Gandhi may have not set a record in
terms of timing, but she could wield an amount
of power that her predecessors definitely
could not boast.
And that power was just about
to increase.
From Strength to Strength
When Mrs. Gandhi was elected, the INC party
was split in two opposing factions.
Of the two, Indira sided with the socialist-leaning
one.
The INC was further weakened when new parliamentary
elections took place in 1967, and the party
lost 60 seats in the lower house.
In normal situations, this landslide defeat
would spell the fall of the cabinet in charge.
But the person in charge of the cabinet was
not your normal Prime Minister.
Indira Gandhi proved that her tenacity to
cling to power was unparalleled.
In order to ensure the survival of her government,
Mrs. Gandhi went as far as forging a coalition
with the Socialist and Communist Parties,
something unthinkable a few years earlier,
during her father Jawaharlal’s term in office.
Why do I say unthinkable?
Nehru may have had a moderate interest in
socialist political and economic reform, but
in the context of the Cold War he definitely
avoided siding with the Socialist Bloc.
Nor with the Capitalist Bloc, for that matter.
Nehru, alongside Egypt’s Nasser and Yugolsavia’s
Tito, was one of the key leaders of the ‘non-aligned’
countries.
While the world debated capitalism versus
communism, India was mostly uninterested in
taking a side.
Now, though, Nehru’s daughter and successor,
far from being an easily swayed ‘doll’,
was taking decisive action to steer India
into a much clearer Socialist direction.
Domestically, in 1969, Mrs Gandhi’s cabinet
nationalised the fourteen largest banks in
India, as well as the four most important
oil companies.
Other reforms included the abolition of privileges
for the Maharajas, who still held power in
several of India’s States.
Finally, Mrs. Gandhi initiated an agricultural
reform based on the Green Revolution concepts
developed by US Scientist Norman Borlaug:
a combination of mechanised agriculture and
development of new breeds of high-yield plants.
Thanks to Gandhi’s reforms, India, normally
beset by periodic famines, became an exporter
of surplus rice and wheat.
As far as foreign policy goes, Indira Gandhi’s
time in office was marked by tension and outright
hostility toward China, Pakistan, and the
US.
At the same time, India signed a Peace, Friendship
and Cooperation treaty with the Soviet Union
in August 1971, marking a further drift away
from equidistant non-alignment and towards
the Socialist Bloc.
But let’s proceed in order.
The enmity with China dated back from the
1962 war and was exacerbated by Beijing’s
nuclear tests in 1967.
The shadow of this atomic threat prompted
Gandhi to start pursuing India’s own nuclear
program.
Within just seven years, the country was able
to perform their first underground detonation.
The rivalry with Pakistan over Kashmir was
as old as India’s independence and had resulted
already in two border wars.
The two countries were about to enter a further
conflict in 1971.
At that time, Pakistan was split into two
separate territories, East and West Pakistan,
separated by Northern India.
Islamabad’s armed forces launched a violent
counter-insurgency campaign in the Eastern
half to suppress the Awami League, an independentist
movement.
The result of this internal struggle was that
about 10 million East Pakistani citizens fled
into India as refugees.
The unprecedented humanitarian crisis stretched
India’s resource to the limit, and it prompted
Indira Gandhi to harshly condemn the repression
on the 31st of March.
Soon, she started doing something more than
just speaking sternly -- Indira started supporting
the Awami League in their independence fight.
This was effectively a war by proxy against
Pakistan, a calculated move to weaken the
hostile neighbour and create a friendlier
government on the North Eastern border.
Toward the end of the year, this local conflict
took on regional, then international connotations.
To put it simply
Pakistan did not like India.
China did not like India.
So, China supported Pakistan.
Enter a new player: the US.
China and the Soviet Union were not best pals
anymore, so Nixon sought a rapprochement with
Mao.
Ergo: the US liked China, who liked Pakistan.
The US planned to help Pakistan, should India
declare war.
All this implies that:
If China dislikes India, and
If the US dislike India,
India is going to make friends with a country
those two also dislike: the Soviet Union.
Hence the Peace, Friendship and Cooperation
treaty I mentioned earlier!
In December of 1971, the conflict by proxy
against Pakistan became a full-fledged war.
On the 3rd of December, Pakistan decided to
retaliate against India’s involvement with
the Awami League by bombing Indian air fields
in the western regions of Punjab and Kashmir.
The Indian government under Indira Gandhi
had proven able to take quick, decisive actions,
and the military was no different.
The Indian air force retaliated on the 4th
and quickly achieved air superiority.
On the ground, the Army launched a quick attack
into East Pakistan, converging on the regional
capital, Dhaka.
On the 9th of December, the war risked escalating
beyond the Indian subcontinent, when Nixon
ordered for a US fleet to head toward the
theater of action.
What may have happened, if the US provided
direct support to Pakistan?
We will never know: by the 16th of December,
Dhaka had fallen to the Indian Army and the
separatist forces of the Awami League.
The Indian victory in the third war with Pakistan
was a personal triumph for Indira Gandhi,
and resulted in the birth of a new nation:
East Pakistan seceded and became Bangladesh.
After the peace had been signed, the Prime
Minister issued a clear warning in an interview
with media, to powers both foreign and domestic:
“I am not a person to be pressured — by
anybody or any nation."
State of Emergency
The 1970s had begun well for Mrs. Gandhi,
and she would soon score another triumph.
In 1972, the INC faced the Socialist Party
in national parliamentary elections.
Gandhi’s party triumphed in the ballot boxes,
thanks to the recent victory over Pakistan
and to her campaign promise to eradicate poverty.
The defeated Socialist leader, Raj Narain,
raised allegations of corruption and electoral
malpractice.
Soon, Socialist and other opposition parties
took to the street, protesting against Gandhi’s
government.
As the decade progressed, Gandhi’s economic
and social reform were largely nullified by
rising inflation and a generally poor state
of the economy.
All this only played in the hands of protesters.
Narain’s charges were formalised with the
High Court in Allahabad, who in June of 1975
ruled against the Prime Minister.
Now Indira Gandhi was constitutionally expected
to step down from office.
But she had already made it clear once: she
wasn’t going to be pressured by anybody.
As unrest spread throughout the country following
the court ruling, Mrs Gandhi took this as
the perfect occasion to declare a state of
emergency, giving her extraordinary powers
to rule by decree.
The period of emergency rule lasted two years,
and it would be a black moment for Indian
democracy.
The country became a dictatorship in all but
name: as an authoritarian ruler, Indira Gandhi
ordered political opponents and other activists
to be jailed, press freedom to be limited.
Indira’s main accomplice and confidante
was her second-born son, Sanjay.
Taking advantage of extraordinary powers,
Sanjay put into practice some pet projects
of his: first, the forced removal of slum
dwellings.
More importantly, India enacted population
control via forced sterilisation.
This draconian measure was considered a necessary
evil to allow for the country to prosper.
Indira’s government launched a campaign
of vasectomies, starting with public employees:
they were required to go through sterilisation
to receive their salaries.
The campaign was then extended to any male
citizen, who would be offered cash, or even
just cooking oil, as an incentive to accept
a vasectomy.
Sanjay’s plans did not stop there: reports
came out that vasectomies had been performed
even on teenage boys, or that men were being
arrested and sterilized.
According to an exposé by TIME magazine,
between April 1976 and January 1977, 7.8 million
Indian boys and men were sterilized -- well
beyond the initial government target of 4.3
million.
At the beginning of 1977, Indira Gandhi put
an end to the state of emergency by calling
for new elections.
The Prime Minister thought that all opposition
had been effectively suppressed, and this
would have been an easy win, one to legitimise
her permanence in office.
But I will take a guess here and say that
one half of the electorate was not too keen
on Gandhi.
You know, the one half that doesn’t like
their manhood to be messed with by forced
surgery …
The elections resulted in a crushing defeat
for the INC: they lost almost 200 seats compared
to the previous legislature.
The big winner this time was the Janata Dal,
or ‘People’s Party’, a coalition of
several smaller parties.
Indira accepted defeat and stepped down.
Blue Star
Mrs Gandhi may have left office as Prime Minister,
but she still held a seat in Parliament, from
which she led the opposition against the Janata
Dal.
The new government tried to remove her by
having her jailed briefly twice: in October
of 1977, and then again in December of 1978.
In both occasions, the charges were corruption.
But the plan did not work.
As the tenuous alliance within the Janata
started to crumble, the electorate called
for stability – something that Indira and
the INC could guarantee.
New elections were called in January 1980,
and Mrs Gandhi made a surprising come back
as head of the Government.
During the same elections, Indira’s son
Sanjay won a seat in parliament.
By May, Mrs Gandhi made it clear that he was
her heir apparent by appointing him as secretary
general of the INC.
Sanjay’s rise had to stop abruptly June
23, 1980.
For years Sanjay had been practising with
some success in the sport of aircraft aerobatics.
That day, too, Sanjay had gone out flying.
But while performing aerial loops, he lost
control and crashed with his plane, dying
on the spot.
Older brother Rajiv also had a passion for
flying; until then he had not shown any interest
in politics, working as a commercial pilot
for Indian Airlines.
But after this tragedy, Indira called him
back into the fold of family politics.
It was clear that she was building the Nehru-Gandhi
dynastic line.
Indira expected the whole family to form a
united front behind Rajiv’s budding political
career, including Maneka, Sanjay’s widow.
But Indira and Maneka had never got on well,
and in 1982, a serious disagreement broke
out between the two.
Maneka attended a rally held by Sanjay's former
political associates, which was perceived
by the Prime Minister as a slight towards
Rajiv.
Indira ordered Maneka to leave the house in
which the extended family all lived together.
The daughter-in-law complied, but first she
made sure the press was aware of her unfair
eviction.
Then, she separated Indira from hers and Sanjay’s
son, Varun.
Not being able to see her grandson was a hard
blow for the Prime Minister.
As it turned out, it became one she could
not recover from, as public troubles piled
on top of the private ones.
By 1982, Mrs. Gandhi had to face the growth
of secessionist movements all over India.
Unrest flared up in the regions of Andhra
Pradesh, Jammu and Kashmir, but the most serious
threat came from the Sikh secessionist movement
in Punjab, Northwestern India.
The movement was led by Jarnail Singh Bhindranwale,
who opposed peaceful negotiations with the
government in Delhi.
In July of 1982, Bhindranwale established
his headquarters within the Harmandir Sahib,
or Golden Temple, in Amritsar, Punjab.
The Golden Temple is the most prominent centre
of worship and pilgrimage for the Sikh faith:
within its walls, Bhindranwale began recruiting
supporters and amassing weapons for an armed
insurrection.
Indira’s government grew more and more concerned
about the Sikh separatist intentions, so eventually,
in February1984, the Prime Minister decided
to go on the offensive.
The initial plan was to have airborne commandos
kidnap Bhindranwale, but this was aborted
in favour of a large scale occupation of the
Golden Temple by Special Forces: ‘Operation
Blue Star’.
Blue Star launched on the night between the
5th and the 6th of June 1984.
The besieged Sikhs answered with heavy fire,
including shooting RPGs at armoured vehicles,
but after a night of fighting, the Indian
commandos seized the Akal Takhat building,
in which Bhindranwale had staged his last
stand.
The palace was hit by light arms fire, tank
shells, and tear gas canisters: by 6am on
the 6th, resistance had ceased and Bhindranwale’s
body was discovered among the rubble.
83 troops lost their lives in the assault,
versus 492 civilian fatalities.
Some of these fatalities were Sikh separatists,
but most were civilians.
The majority of the dead were pilgrims who
happened to be inside the temple at the wrong
time.
Operation Blue Star was followed by Operation
Woodrose, a larger military deployment which
included infantry, armour, artillery, and
helicopters confronting Sikh independentists
across all of Punjab.
Both operations widened the rift between the
Sikh minority and the rest of the country.
Indira Gandhi’s prestige and popularity,
which had made a recovery since the 1980 re-election,
were heavily tarnished once again.
But something much, much worse than a dip
in popularity was on the horizon for the Prime
Minister.
On the morning of October 31st, 1984, Indira
Gandhi was walking from her official residence
toward her office to meet British actor Peter
Ustinov, who was there to interview her for
a BBC documentary.
She was walking a few paces ahead of her attendant,
as she approached the gates leading out of
her gardens.
At 9:09 am, Mrs Gandhi folded her hands to
greet the two bodyguards stationed at the
gates, Beant Singh and Satwant Singh.
These guards were not related.
The Sanskrit word ‘Singh’ means lion,
and it is an essential component of all male
names among the Sikhs.
It was only four months since Operations Blue
Star and Woodrose, but the Prime Minister
had no reason to mistrust her loyal Sikh bodyguards.
In the case of Beant and Satwant, she had
made a mistake: the two had been planning
their revenge for the massacre at the Golden
Temple.
Beant fired the first shots with his revolver,
followed by Satwant, who fired his Sten submachine
gun on full auto.
Indira Gandhi was shot 30 times.
She was rushed to a hospital, but her death
was announced at 1 pm the same day.
The following day, ordinary citizens, in many
cases aided and supported by police and local
authorities, started a series of violent anti-Sikh
riots, which resulted in the death of more
than 3,000 Sikhs.
The death of a leader had sparked a period
of unrest for her country – but that’s
another story.
Legacy
Indira Gandhi had built her political career
on the principle of bold action, independent
from external pressure.
This had led to successes like the Green revolution,
the victory against Pakistan, the alliance
with the USSR, and a stable nuclear programme.
Indira also succeeded in ensuring the continuation
of the Nehru/Gandhi dynasty.
Shortly after the assassination, her son Rajiv
was sworn in as new Prime Minister.
Rajiv remained in power for seven years, until
he, too, was assassinated in May 1991 by a
suicide bomber from aSri Lankan militant group,
known as the ‘Tamil Tigers’.
In 1997, Rajiv’s wife Sonia was elected
by INC members as their party President, a
key role in setting the policies of the Country
. Sonia Gandhi could have easily won over
the seat of Prime Minister.
But the fact that she is Italian by birth,
did not allow her to cover official Government
functions, let alone become the head of said
Government.
In 2017, Sonia continued the Dynastic tradition
and handed over direction of the party to
her son Rahul.
However, this was the story of a strong leader,
and as usual, there are shadows behind the
triumphs.
It is not possible to overlook the excesses
of the emergency years, the allegations of
corruption, the poor management of the economy
and finally the immediate and lasting effects
of Operation Blue Star.